The characters in the Final Destination franchise
really only have one way of protecting themselves
when Death decides that it’s their time,
and that is to look for the signs and try
to avoid them.
Some of these signs, however, go unnoticed,
not only by the characters, but also by the
majority of movie audiences.
In the first minute of the opening credits,
there’s this weird keychain that leaves
a shadow that looks like a man hanging by
the neck.
This is how Death would eventually take out
Alex’s friend Tod who accidentally gets
his neck wrapped around a bathroom clothesline.
Shortly after, Alex is preparing to leave
for France and grabs his Touring France book.
The next book behind it on the stack is Death
of a Salesman, which ends with an automobile
induced death which is a sign about one of Final
Destination’s second main character, Terry.
And no, that’s not a Death of a Salesman
spoiler, it’s in the title, OK?
Then, the fan blows open the Touring France
book to A History Lesson page, where we see
a picture of the gallows that were used in
France in the middle ages.
The character Billy would also be executed
by beheading, when a piece of scrap metal
shot out from under a train.
And moments later, it flips to a page about
Jim Morrison’s tomb with the words, “This
Is The End” graffitied onto it.
Not only is this just a general omen about
death, but Jim Morrison actually died while
in Paris, a fate shared with Carter at the
end of Final Destination.
There would be many more signs, weird coincidences
that aren’t coincidences and hidden secrets
in Final Destination, so stick around to the
end of this video to hear about the craziest
one.
Welcome to Things You Missed, this is a show
where I analyse all the hidden secrets and
overlooked details in your favorite horror
films, and Final Destination
is going to be an interesting one to cover,
because the whole idea is that everything
is Death’s design.
“In death, there are no accidents.
No coincidences.
No mishaps.
And no escapes.”
So whenever there are weird little moments
of chance or details that may or may not be
intentional, I might normally leave them off
the Things You Missed, or at least mention
a disclaimer that I don’t know if they’re
intentional.
But with Final Destination, we’ve already
been told not to doubt that these details
are meaningful.
So for example, Alex’s birthday is September
25th, 9/25, and the flight desk agent points
out that his flight leaves at 9:25PM.
But did you also notice his assigned seat
is in Row 25, Seat I, which is the ninth seat
from the right?
Did you notice the song Carter and Terry listen
to in the car?
Into the Void is a track by the band Nine
Inch Nails; a song with exactly 25 lines.
The lyrics of this song talk about the singer
trying to save himself, just like the characters
in this movie.
The first verse almost seems to line up perfectly
with what Alex goes through in the opening.
Talking to myself all the way to the station.
Pictures in my head of the Final Destination.
All lined up, all the ones that aren't allowed
to stay.
Tried to save myself but myself keeps slipping
away.
We’re just scratching the surface of this,
get it?
Cause Nine Inch Nails?
Scratching the surface?
I don’t like that joke either.
Let’s get into the Things You Missed.
Into the Void wasn’t the only song with
a deeper meaning in Final Destination.
The one that comes up over and over is Rocky
Mountain High.
We first hear it in the airport restroom,
where Alex makes the connection about the
artist, John Denver, having died in a plane
crash.
“John Denver.
Died in a plane crash.”
The opening line of that song speaks of a
27 year old.
🎵 “He was born in the summer of his 27th
year.” 🎵
Twenty-seven is the age that Jim Morrison,
who was referenced earlier, died in Paris.
Another lyric mentions a fire in the sky.
🎵 “I’ve seen it raining fire in the
sky.” 🎵
...which is what witnesses saw during the
explosion on Flight 180.
This song becomes an omen of death for those
who got off the plane.
Tod momentarily plugs in a radio before his
death.
🎵 Colorado Rocky Mountain high! 🎵
Ms. Lewton puts on the record before her final
moments.
🎵 Rocky Mountain High - John Denver 🎵
And in the final scene, a street performer
covers the song in French.
Outside of music, there are other things that
connect each of the accidents.
Since the seven who got off the plane were
supposed to die on route to France there are
many references to the country of France seen in each
disaster scene.
Let’s call them The French Connections.
For context, that is a better joke than the
one I made earlier, but only slightly.
I’ll start with the plane.
Flight 180’s aircraft has blue, white and
red stripes reminiscent of the French flag.
Makes sense, it’s a French airline.
But that doesn’t explain, why the bus that
hits Terry has blue white and red stripes,
or why the train that crashes into Carter’s
car is also lined with blue, white and red.
It might also be worth mentioning that Billy is
also seen wearing blue, white and red on a
couple of occasions.
When we first meet him he’s got on a Rangers
jersey and in the scene where he is decapitated,
he has a flannel with blue, white and red
stripes.
Outside of the French flags, there are other
France and Paris references.
In the airport, the only other Paris flight
that night is cancelled, and in the terminal,
Clear is reading Tropic of Cancer by Henry
Miller, which was notably written in France.
The room they are moved to after the crash
has clocks for several cities across the globe,
but the one we see on screen is Paris.
When Death comes for Clear at the climax of
the movie, she burns a candle for light, and
we see four miniature Eiffel Towers, and when
Clear and Alex grab coffee together they sit
outdoors in a cafe, clearly inspired by the
street corner cafes that dominate much of
the city of Paris.
At the end of the movie, they sit and have
a drink at a real French cafe, moments before
Death makes an attempt on Alex and Carter
before the movie ends, which is teached at
by a few interesting books seen on Ms. Lewton’s
bookshelf, most notably End Game In Paris.
The teacher’s bookshelf also had some other
interesting titles, that can lead us to discover
even more secrets.
One of the other book titles on Ms. Lewton’s
shelf that I found to maybe have a deeper
meaning was “The Cradle Will Fall”, a
1980 novel by Mary Higgins Clark.
Perhaps this title is a reference to the unusually
high number of young high school kids aboard
Flight 180 when it fell out of the sky.
Or perhaps a reference to that fact that there
was a baby on board the flight?
Also, why has there not been a Final Destination
movie where the victims are all babies?
Like a hospital nurse has a vision that helps
her prevent a gas leak in the nursery, and
now Death is coming for all these newborns
and the parents have to protect their kids
from a series of disasters?
It would be the ultimate horror movie for
first time parents.
The other book that Ms. Lewton has is called
“Heads.”
I’m sure you can find the significance behind
that one on your own.
You may have also noticed Ms. Lewton’s first
name.
“Hi, this is Valerie Lewton I need Agent
Shrek.”
“Are you talking to… me?”
Ms. Valerie Lewton is a reference to Val Lewton,
one of the most prolific horror film producers,
who made classics like Cat People, I Walked
With A Zombie, and…
The Seventh Victim.
There are seven victims that Death comes for
after escaping Flight 180.
There are other characters whose names pay
homage to classic horror icons.
The other French teacher was named Mr. Murnau,
after FW Murnau.
Terry Chaney was named for Lon Chaney, Alex
Browning for Tod Browning (and by the way
Alex’s friend Tod spells his name with one
D, just like Tod Browning did), Tod’s brother
is named George Waggner, named directly after
George Waggner, Blake Dreyer for Carl Theodor
Dreyer and Billy Hitchcock for Alfred Hitchcock,
the director of films like Strangers on a
Train (Billy is killed by a train) and The
39 Steps.
There are 39 people from Mt Abraham High School
who died on Flight 180.
The survivors meet with investigators 39 minutes
after the departure time and the memorial
is held 39 days after the accident.
Tod dies at 10:39PM and Ms. Lewton dies at
home.
Her street address?
39.
The memorial statue is a bird.
The Volée 180 victims died while in flight.
I don’t know if this is coincidence, or
the intention of the person who designed the
statue, but like I mentioned at the beginning
of this video, I’m not gonna worry about
that as long as I’m covering Final Destination.
Of course, while 39 did pass away, there were
7 survivors.
After Terry’s death, the number 7 is splattered
onto Alex’s cheek in blood, and he was scheduled
to be last on Death’s list -- he was #7.
Thirty-nine lost plus seven survived equals
46 total on the field trip.
The flight takes off out of Gate 46.
Alex’s address is 4688.
On the topic of Flight 180, the trip is booked
on Volée Airlines.
Volée is a French word meaning “stolen”.
Alex and the others have stolen additional
time from Death.
One of the other things in the opening credits
is when the wind blows and this book flips
through pages on the Devil, Evil, Damnation
and other topics, including a photo of someone
holding a cross to the devil, the same way
a fourth quarter lead up to the Atlanta Falcons.
Then, when Alex boards the aircraft, he looks
down and sees a luggage cart with the number
of the devil: 666.
After that, the series doesn’t really make
mention of anything demonic, instead, just
focusing on The Grim Reaper, but as more of
a natural force than an entity.
But I wonder if the demonic imagery at the
beginning is a suggestion that those who try
to cheat death would be confined to hell.
“Disrespecting the design could incite a
fury that could terrorize even the grim reaper.”
On the other end of the spectrum from the
Devil, is God.
In Alex's room, there’s a poster that reads:
“At one point he wanted to become a priest.
He settled for being a God.
I believe that’s a photo a Babe Ruth, and
with a career OPS of 1.164, I’ve got to
agree with the poster.
Of course, Alex lives on Long Island, New
York, and it’s even mentioned that he and
Tod are Yankee fans, so this poster makes
sense, but is it a sign of things to come
for Alex?
ALEX: “If I see it, then I intervene, and if
I intervene, I change the design.”
CARTER: “What? Intervene? What are you God now?”
ALEX: “God’s not afraid to die.
Gods don’t die.
We do.”
Maybe Alex’s awareness about his mortality
is also the reason he can’t stop focusing
on the word “Terminal” at the airport.
Or maybe that’s just another side effect
of his clairvoyant abilities.
There are actually many more signs about the
fate of each character that Death comes for
outside of the ones I’ve already mentioned.
The night of the plane crash, Alex sees lightning
strike his street, and at the cabin, lightning
shoots out of his lighter.
These are both clues about the storm that
nearly took Clear’s life later on.
The coroner explains that every move we make
is part of Death’s design, and one of the
examples he uses is “the red light we stop
at, or run.”
Then, not long after Alex uses a similar example
while trying to explain his theory.
He says that crossing an intersection could
lead to death.
Sure enough, Terry’s death is the result
of a run light in an intersection.
It happens shortly after Clear tells Alex,
“You can find death omens anywhere you want
to,” and he looks up to see the reflection
of a bus that isn’t really there.
The next victim is Ms. Lewton.
After she gets done packing the codpiece that
she has… for some reason… she’s attacked
by an exploding computer monitor and falls
against the stained glass window with an image
of a dagger, foreshadowing the knife she ultimately
ends up getting stabbed with.
Alex realizes something is wrong when he’s
walking outside and sees a neighbor burning
a pile of leaves.
This was his sign that Ms. Lewton would accidentally
start a fire inside her home.
And when that fire is ignited, there’s a
moving box in the background, made by a brand
called “Shadow Transfer.”
In this movie, Death is never seen, but sometimes
a shadow casts over them, and whenever a character
passes away or evades Death, the target is
transferred on to the next person.
There is also a set order -- the survivors
are supposed to die in the same order they
would have gone out in during the plane crash.
Like the dominos on coffee table in Alex’s
home, they are set up to fall in order.
That’s how Alex knows that Ms. Lewton is
going to be next after Terry.
He goes into the house, makes sure to leave
behind his fingerprint on the murder weapon
and his shoeprint on the floor.
MOVIE CHARACTERS.
WHY ARE YOU LIKE THIS?
At least wipe it down afterwards.
You know what?
I need to save my yelling voice for the second
and fourth ones.
Next in line is Carter.
Death’s plan for him is a collision with
a train, because these movies are all about
Planes, Trains and Automobiles....
And Shrek.
“This is Agent Shrek.”
🎵 Shrekophone 🎵
But when Alex sees the premonition about the
train, he sees train number 747, which links
back to the type of aircraft they narrowly
escaped in the opening, a Boeing 747.
Finally, when Alex, Clear and Carter think
it’s over, and they’ve survived, Clear
spills her wine on the able and Alex’s name
on the airport seating chart looks as if it
is stained in blood, and that’s when he
knows… that he should stay tuned, because
we’ve got even more hidden details to uncover…
After surviving the disastrous Volée Flight
180, Alex becomes obsessed with learning how
the crash might have occured on a technical
level, collecting books, manuals and newspapers
to learn as much as possible.
He comes across an article about the memorial
service held at his school and the author
of the article is a reference to the Art Department
Coordinator of the movie.
There’s also an article on the side written
by the assistant art director.
Another newspaper headlines: High School Teacher
Dies In Mysterious Blaze, and a nearby article
is authored by another member of the art department.
There easter eggs, which I’ve come to call
“crew reference easter eggs” are seen
in a lot of movies, but Final Destination
might be record setter, at least as far as
the movies I’ve covered here on Things You
Missed go.
Most of it is thanks to the Flight 180 memorial
itself, where all but a few of the listed
victims are just random names who worked on
Final Destination, so rather, than reading
them all out, you can just pause the video
if you want to see them for yourself.
The only other notable crew reference easter
egg can be found outside Ms. Lewton’s house.
As you know, she’s planning on moving away,
so she has a realtor sign in her yard, and
it looks like the name of the realtor is C
Kristen, whereas the actual actress that plays
Ms. Lewton is a Kristen C.
In this video, I’ve focused a lot on the
signs of impending death, but there may also
be clues about future relationships.
I mean, the obvious one is when Alex pulls
out the Penthouse Magazine immediately after
seeing the photo of Clear in the newspaper,
I mean I always thought that was a weird thing
to include in the movie, that’s just his
immediate reaction, but the less obvious one
would be towards the end, when he’s trying
to save her life in the lightning storm.
Clear is trapped in the car and they’re
separated by the window as he tries to tell
her what to do.
In the corner of the window, there’s a little
bit of pro-seatbelt propaganda, showing the
buckle and the release with the words: Get
Together, which is exactly what Alex and Clear
do sometime during the six month time gap
before the final scene in Paris.
But before we get to that final scene, there
is one more pattern that I have to point out,
because it continues on into all the Final
Destination sequels so far.
Every disaster scene in the movie, is somehow
connected to water. Or at least liquid.
The first example is the least obvious, the
plane crash.
If you’re familiar with the geography, this
makes sense, but even if you aren’t you’ll
find out later in the movie that the plane
crashed into the ocean, somewhere beyond Jones
Beach, which is where Alex goes to hide out
and ponder the possibilities of other dimensions.
Next is the Tod strangulation scene, which
is obviously caused when he slips on the leaked
toilet water.
Side note, this is the only disaster scene
in the series that really seems to suggest
there is something supernatural at play, because
of the way the water recedes after Tod’s
name is added to the body count.
I tried finding the scene YouTube to see if
anyone had any interesting takes on this,
but all I found was our man Jhonwil from 10
years ago saying, “The way those green liquid
substance go on towards him really scares
me…”
So, all I learned was basically what I already
knew: that I love reading the YouTube comments.
Terry's death happens while they're getting drinks, so not a lot to say there. I mean, this time the liquid is coffee rather than water.
Ms. Lewton’s disaster scene is next, and
it all starts with her boiling water, which
ends up being replaced with vodka, which seeps
out of her mug and into the the computer monitor,
which somehow makes the monitor explode.
The next disaster is the one at the railroad
tracks, where Carter avoids Death, but Billy,
the next in line, does not.
It’s dark out, so it’s a bit hard to see
when it happens, but it is raining during
this scene.
It’s a little bit more obvious when they’re in
the car shortly before.
This, of course, is the last one before the
big lightning storm that was supposed to take
out Clear.
Obviously, there’s a bunch of water in this
one: the rain, the fact that Alex travels
to her house in a canoe in the middle of a
lightning storm (which, in any other movie
would be the dumbest idea in the movie, but
in Final Destination, we’ll just call it
ONE of the dumbest ideas in the movie) and
then Alex almost gets the David Dunn treatment
from a tree,
...and then there's the whole thing with the pool flooding the area,
so really this one is filled
with water.
There are also other water connections that
aren’t necessarily part of the disasters,
like when Alex is having his “alone time”
with the magazine, the model is standing in
the water, then there’s a part where Clear
and Alex put Alka Seltzer in their water glasses
at the exact same time (maybe another clue
about their upcoming relationship), and just the girl’s
name: Clear Rivers, it’s one of the wateriest
names I’ve ever heard.
So that finally takes us to the big conclusion
in Paris.
We can see that the ground is wet, and I already
mentioned Clear’s spilled drink, so the
water / liquid theme is still there, but the
BIG connection can be seen after that.
Alex narrowly avoids getting hit by a bus,
which swerves into a lamppost, which knocks
loose the sign for this restaurant, Le Cafe
Miro 81.
Carter miraculously saves him from getting
hit by the sign, but when it swings back around
towards them, we’re seeing the backside
of the broken off portion of the sign, giving
it the appearance of 180.
Volée Flight 180 was not done with them yet.
I’m gonna be covering the entire Final Destination
franchise, so look out for the next episode
of Things You Missed in that playlist on the
left.
If you love horror remember to subscribe to
CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
the deathbell to select all notifications
and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.
If you want to beat death, I recommend a facemask
and social distancing.